okay I sort of alluded to this next
question the third audience question
today is David does the middle ground on
abortion exist I heard you mentioned on
the Joe Rogan program that you can't
include any crazy idea in the discussion
but is there a middle ground on the
issue of abortion there is a middle
ground on the issue of abortion only
when you've narrowed the conversation in
a pretty significant way and what I mean
by that is if your position is abortion
is murder and it should be illegal I
don't know how you find a middle ground
with that person that has any kind of
legal abortion I mean the fundamentals
of how different political factions see
abortion as an issue
unfortunately prevent productive
dialogue in a lot of ways my view is
that this shouldn't even be a discussion
there are lots of legal medical
procedures that if we see a video of
maybe rappelling in some way this for me
includes you know I don't want to watch
a heart bypass I don't think it should
be illegal doesn't mean I want to watch
abortions but that doesn't mean those
should be illegal however if you are
brought to the table with someone who
says any abortion is murder
because you know one day after
conception that is a person I don't know
how you actually find a middle ground
there now I do think that what's really
different about abortion than many other
issues is the outcome that the left and
right at least claim to want and I
believe do want is actually the same the
left and right both don't want abortions
so so when you talk to the right they
don't want abortion to be legal or
accessible because they believe that it
is murder when you talk to people on the
left they don't want abortions to be
necessary and they want to reduce the
number with sex education and
contraceptives and so on and so forth
but they do believe that abortion should
be legal and safe that's why it's been
so interesting to see the resistance
from the right to say hey you know what
the left actually does share the goal of
reducing the number of abortions
empirical studies tell us how to do it
and it's with safe and and legal safe
and full and
expensive access to birth control as
well as comprehensive sex education they
don't want that and a lot of this
relates to what George Lake off
describes a strict father morality where
it doesn't fit into the moral framework
of many on the right that you would be
able to have recreational
non-procreative sex outside of a
marriage and have a tool that prevents
pregnancy there's too many people on the
right who for moral reasons believe that
sex should be two different degrees
between married heterosexual couples for
the purposes of procreation and if you
do choose to have sex outside of
marriage then you don't deserve it's not
right morally to have a way to prevent a
pregnancy because that would be chaos
and we know sort of all of the other
beliefs that come with that
so the the the last thing I'll say on
this is the right has very successfully
actually managed the issue of abortion
despite the fact that over time the
average position in the United States on
abortion has moved towards I believe it
should be legal in most cases more than
half of the country now believes that
when the right continues to have these
extreme positions sprinkled in at least
any abortion should be illegal these
marches for life right to life marches
where it gets completely wacky I mean
really really wacky speeches and crazy
crazy stuff they pulled the Overton
Window to the right and may benefit from
this that's the reality it puts the
pro-choice contingent on having to
defend even abortion being being legal
rather than getting to the real issues
of providing contraception to people sex
education etc so unfortunately the right
has succeeded partially because they
have used extreme positions to pull the
debate to the right partially because
their framing is really simple abortion
is murder and we shouldn't do it whereas
the position on the left is not
abortions all the time no matter what
it's yes we would like to reduce
abortions but you have to take into
consideration all of these other factors
etc etc and George Lakoff has written a
lot about that as well send me your
thoughts is there something that we
could call a middle ground on abortion
when one side of the debate believes
that any abortion is bird murder they
should all be a
the law and all sorts of different
people should be punished whether it's
the doctors the mothers or whoever else
let me know what you think we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you today
become a member or a patron to get
instant access to the bonus show
otherwise I will be back with you with a
new show on Monday